reached that 117 all-time high that
we've ever hit in las vegas we hit it
again
five times now that we've done that here
in las vegas that was saturday
still have a little bit of that haze
yesterday was just brown air
all through the las vegas valley that
was wildfire smoke coming up
from arizona with that southeasterly
flow that also brought in the monsoon
moisture
which we saw turn into thunderstorms
late last night maybe you slept through
it maybe you didn't
had a lot of lightning with it 90s just
about everywhere
except some 80's in summerlin mountain's
edge centennial hills
and red rock this morning we've got 82
at indian springs 87 in trump 84 at
sandy valley near 90 in mesquite
some good rain up in the moapa valley
last night and out to lake mead
95 in laflin 104 in death valley right
now
hit 128 yesterday 130 degrees on
saturday
out at death valley we picked up a 10th
of an inch of rain last night had some
40 mile per hour outflow winds
strong gusty winds put a lot of debris
in the roads bianca will talk more about
that
about an inch of rain now barely almost
an inch for the year
we're about an inch and a quarter behind
for the year some neighborhoods though
picked up
more than that 10th of an inch almost a
half an inch
up there at 95 and lee canyon road so we
picked up some nice rainfall
but it was almost four tenths of an inch
up in the moapa valley you can see that
lightning complex
was really intense in the moapa valley
with some flooded roads up there again
overnight most of that shifted off to
the east we could see thunderstorms
again
late today into tonight excessive heat
warnings will last until 8 o'clock
and then they should be over along with
heat advisories for the mountains 114
ties the record high for today that
slight chance of thunderstorms again
tuesday before we dry out
and get temperatures below 110
for the rest of the week